host of the midnight SportsCenter and
emmy-nominated and deserving of every
last word I just said he is Scott Van
Pelt calling in from the grounds of
Augusta National how are you Scott I'm
calling in from the grounds of Augusta
National's so everything is just right I
bet I don't you made a deed the Sun is
out my favorite day of the year the
par-3 contest in the afternoon a little
preview show and then you tee it up on
Thursday I'm really good I bet and um do
you practice the golf voice throughout
the year cuz um you know I'm to get it
ready or does it just come naturally for
you when you when you when you broadcast
from there I try to be myself I try not
to change but I think there's a certain
there's a high I do less I do less rap
references this week like I got I don't
slip into DMX I mean which would
actually be great but no I mean it's not
full of some that you're that you're
just this place it it makes you feel a
certain way and but but Mike Tirico and
I talked about this and when we first
got the master and Mike was our host
I think I think we got in everyone's
heads like we were supposed to be
different and no one here is telling you
to be different right you know there's
just I just be yourself so I I mean
people would joke around me and say oh
there's masters Van Pelt or Sports
Center Van Pelt I think okay well maybe
that's accurate there's bit there just
it's a different it's just a different
vibe but I try my best to be myself no
no well I I do too at the combine but
when it's quiet out in in Lucas Oil and
you can hear the buzz of the lights as
somebody gets on a 40-yard dash line you
know I just kind of get into the moment
not to say that Augusta National and
Lucas Oil have much in common except for
T in the and Lucas in Lucas Oil and the
first he is Augusta very similar well
you should see grass you should see the
way that they bring back the legends of
the 40-yard dash to run the first 40
yard dash ceremonially I mean it's just
it's fantastic yeah we should we should
we should start covering that [ __ ]
on the NFL Network yeah you know an
interesting that just to continue this
analogy the part three contest that's on
ESPN at 3:00 Eastern Time
getting the coverage that it gets now
more and more every year it's kind of
like the jacket ceremony at the Hall of
Fame where it's like this hidden gem
that's been played over and over and
over again that now gets the national
coverage that it deserves and people are
just loved watching it and loved being
there that's what it feels like to me
that's now that's an absolutely spot-on
and I totally agree with it it's the
type of thing that people just crave the
access to to those moments right and and
the quarry concert is that it's in
what's interesting to me riches I mean
so there's four majors here so you got
sixteen rounds and there's a most
important 16 last year that's played and
we intermediate certainly turn them into
more than just a round of golf which the
player is sort of giggle at and say you
know it's still just golf
yet the stakes are high it's understood
there's going to be stress there's going
to be tension and the day before it
you're out there running around maybe
with your kids and the caddie right and
it couldn't be less stressful it is just
it's a perfect afternoon and it's a
great way to diffuse a little of that
stress before you you know start
sharpening up your pencil and adding it
up for real Scott Van Pelt here on the
Rich Eisen show so how does how does one
handicap the favorites coming in how
they've played over the last few weeks
the week before or just they've never
won it before and it's time in your
estimation I mean how does one figure
out who the favorite to win the Masters
is Scott I I think Richards the most
difficult tournament of the year to
handicap for exactly what you're the big
question that you're asking because
let's say you're Rory McIlroy or you're
Justin Rose and you've never won here
but you if you're Rory you've finished
top ten the last five times you played
here if you're Justin Rose you've been
runner-up twice in the last four years I
would say having played well here most
having played well here in the past is
more important than having played well
recently but if you're Rory and you
played well here recently and you've won
recently then that puts you in a
different category and of the player
ten in the world I believe nine have won
this season so you've got that on your
side but then you got a guy like Tiger
who okay well he hasn't won this year
but he's won here four times so I think
what I'm getting to is that what we
create is a lengthy list of players most
of whom were really decorated or highly
rated who you think well sure he could
win I mean I choked with Andy yesterday
we were on the air here for hours doing
the press conferences as I said I think
Andy you pretty much you're like my
towel in the tournament I think you've
predicted 12 people are going to win and
by rule that there will be one green
jacket on Sunday so I find it incredibly
difficult to to narrow down the focus to
just a couple whereas there's at least a
handful to 10 guys that you think oh
absolutely it could be his time and then
when you hear the phrase this is my
favorite golf phrase course is set up
perfectly for this person you know and
that's that's kind of like the
pound-for-pound in boxing right you
gotta you got to figure out what what
does that mean
so what does that mean for for the
Masters who does this course set up well
for a long list because they're very few
people discounts is the issue like I
mean Dustin Johnson hasn't played great
here and he's now number two in the
world but you'd think he's got the game
he hit it a mile hits a mile in the air
can gets tricky with the putter but he
likes to cut the ball and it's more
right to less than it is left to right
if you're right-handed so that doesn't
discount him but like a player again
Justin Rose says this golf course just
absolutely suits my eye and you look at
like the Texas Tech Virginia game the
other night either team could have won
at the end it would have felt like an
appropriate outcome like the right team
won well Rose could have easily won here
two years ago but he lost in a playoff
to Sergio so he is on that very very
short list of you know horse horses for
courses when it comes to the Masters
Rose I mean
rightfully will be on the list of
everyone that will say oh he he could /
should win eventually but this course
had a long list of those guys rich
Norman was supposed to win Weiskopf was
supposed to win Duval was supposed to
win Wells was supposed to win they never
did so you
your moments here van you better grab it
what's the weather look like for the
tournament
not great in perfect right now it's
again today's the day you dream of its
in its I love that it's here for wins
because I love Wednesday player outside
of Thursday looks pretty good every day
has that that ugly little lightning bolt
in the in the weather forecast with
which that's the one thing that stops
play and so I would imagine that from
Thursday through Sunday will probably
have a little bit of fits and starts you
play a bit maybe you have to sit for a
bit
I'm afraid weather will impact it so all
you can do is cross your fingers and see
what happens so then your tap dance
routine literal tap dance soft-shoe
routine in butler cabin is that what
we're gonna have had fill the the rain
too late on Scott you got something
planned I got some on I've got some
spectacular Tom Ford's I don't want to
names on you but I mean it's me if need
be
I can I could I could give you a little
hop shoe in these but I really had they
discussed these up okay I'm gonna try to
send them back because they were rather
prices what is the coolest item in
Butler cabin what is that when you're
sitting in there and you're looking
around like what is like okay that one
if if I could get away with it I would
take honest that's and that's the
amazing thing it's it is I mean if I say
Spartan and that makes it sound like
it's not nice if it's nice it's just
there's not a great deal in it there's I
think they move most of the stuff that
is in there out to accommodate for
television so there's really just a few
chairs and some monitors and it's not
like there are little trinkets and
things of that nature
I've joked it for years the coolest
thing is when you get to have a bite in
the grill and the plates are these very
they're these beautiful pieces of china
but that's flatware I guess say and it's
got the logo on it and I joked with the
guys because I've gotten to know the
folks in there I said you know I'm gonna
I'm gonna take one of these and they're
like I hope you enjoyed your time of the
gun placement one place you could not
they're kidding I think at the door that
there'd be somebody in a hurry and a
Pinkertons outfit would very quietly
grab my arm mr. Van Thal can you come
with us and then they just they
walk me out the gates to Washington Road
and that'd be the end then we had I I'm
not lifting anything man I'm just happy
they let me put Park Park like a couple
of days and and I don't want to do I
don't want to get taken out on a B&E
there's no there's no Biff Biff Loman
and Scott Van Pelt hey before I let you
go I do want to have you chime in on
Magic Johnson and what happened here in
Los Angeles last night it truly is in
the quarter century that I've been
fortunate enough to cover national
sports top five most bizarre scenario as
I said to open the show today all-time
great player
certainly all-time great player for the
franchise quits franchise doesn't tell
boss tells media and walks out of the
arena after an hour's worth of bizarre
back and forth and soul pouring out to
the media Scott what what are your tests
was on it wait cuz he wants to tweet and
say nice stuff about other guys I was at
a function and a guy pulled me to the
side said hey Magic Johnson was quit now
was late in the evening and I thought
okay well you've just had a bottle of
wine that's right you've done and you're
telling me nonsense and then of course
you do what you do in 2019 I go on
Twitter and I look at glow just timeline
I'm like oh my god right like right and
then I come home and I'm trying to
construct back like is this as odd as it
seems and it is it's odder than it seems
I don't know what to make of it look you
know you know what we traffic in at ESPN
you've lived a life I mean the Lakers
are a storyline all year and then it
goes wrong but then to have this happen
with their most iconic player not an
iconic player their most iconic player
basically tap out maybe it has something
to do with Luke wall maybe it has
something to do the one who tweet I
don't know like it's just a year ago not
quite a year ago in July of last year
rich when we were all you know panting
over LeBron to LA and what it might mean
I none of us thought this was it and
I've seen theories that magic knows none
of it no free agents are coming this
summer he just wants to punt before that
happens I don't know if that's the case
but I mean it's just a stunning and an
incredibly bizarre way for
him to just literally tap out I'm out
and there he goes I mean I can't I can't
put two and two together here I think
it's just truly he just couldn't cut it
and it's tough to say that about one of
the most popular and beloved sports
figures just couldn't cut it and maybe
that does the the Lakers a favor to give
them I guess the Rheem unthe
to put something together in time for
free agency that has a resemblance of
and I can't believe I'm about to finish
this sentence a resemblance of
competencies so they could bring people
to LA over the Clippers you know that's
crazy
you're exactly look at the Clippers are
the Clippers from what I've been told
are a much more attractive destination
to most of the the high high-end players
but you know what rich did the part
about not cutting it I mean you're not a
good broadcaster you're great
broadcaster you're a great host but does
that mean you could slap on a headset
and go produce probably not maybe but
but I shouldn't say probably not maybe
not maybe you'd go sit down in the chair
and you couldn't back time a show and
you couldn't figure out how to stack the
A's and the B's and this is real inside
the media but what I'm saying doesn't
mean that he could figure out what that
what that entails and maybe for magic he
just didn't look he's got incredible
business acumen and success that has
nothing to do with this maybe it's just
like no I don't want to do this you know
maybe that's it yeah but there's got to
be a better way to exit the stage than
that Scott really appreciate the time
enjoy the day and enjoy the Masters and
enjoy everything else we'll chat with
you down the line I look forward to a
rich thanks for having me and maybe well
you bet you the man that's a Scott Van
Pelt at not the fake SVP on Twitter for
more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 under red TV for
free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app